are you familiar with neil donald walsh
um
no but i am familiar with uh neil
armstrong is he the same
neil donald walsh wrote a series of
books called conversations with god i've
heard of that and i love that we both
love that it's a rat yeah okay it's
super rad and the concept there is that
um
that
the universe god
is uh
absolute love pure love but
being absolute
just one thing you know we we're all
familiar with the concept of oneness you
know we are all one but as just one
thing
being absolute love
it has no uh
ability to have experience because it's
only one thing it needs another
something to relate to a reflection of
itself right
so
so the the actual universe this is the
theory the universe is
an exercise in that absolute
love
experiencing itself where it divides
itself into a multitude of parts so that
each part can relate to the other part
and only and in that move
you go from the absolute realm to the
relative realm yeah and relative meaning
that you can't have
nothing can be cold unless you have hot
yup you know nothing can always happen
unless you have down yeah and so it's
all you know that division of the
absolute creates the ability for there
to be experience yep i totally subscribe
to that and thus we are all and and all
of creation is an exercise in god
experiencing itself totally and i think
like you know there's a guy wrote a
fascinating book called my big toe the
theory of everything is this like
crazy physicist trying to figure out how
it all works and he said the same thing
if there is like one source unified mind
the only way for it to evolve because
you devolve or evolve is to break off
pieces of itself and learn lessons
without knowing the answer they're like
we're in a quiz and if someone goes dude
you can die you're immortal you're fine
you're like oh [ __ ] then [ __ ] it i'll
jump in front of a train you know
no nothing matters but if you don't know
that then you'll act differently and
you'll learn differently and you'll
you'll have compassion and all these
different things and i and and then
source
can grow and i think the but the
difference here is what's interesting is
the way i the way i see it in my mind
it's imagine you have like the shoe box
of light and that's like the [ __ ]
love you know everything's combined and
we're all one and then you have a shoe
box of pitch blackness that's the
absence of that and then you shove them
together
and all the light goes dark but all
you're left with these little specks of
light in the darkness those are like
stars
and those are spitting out and those
grow out onto planets and create these
little life forms that experience thing
and everything's existing in the same
place
and that's where you get kind of the
geometries the the you know this they
show you those shapes where the
staircases spiral down or plants grow in
a spiral it's like holographic like like
everything is existing within the same
location going into itself almost like
um
a hologram if you look at it and i see a
picture of you in 3d and i break it into
like a bunch of glass pieces every piece
contains you did you know that i can
take a broken piece of that hologram and
look down and i'll see your whole body
even though it's just like your ear you
know it's like that's that's just every
hologram that we [ __ ] around with and we
print with lasers and do something funny
are cool with it but that's kind of how
the universe is it's like everything's
within itself yeah somebody uh
just said one line that i just grabbed
onto so much
um
we are all eyes in the same head
that's pretty interesting
we are all
dicks in the same underpants
same pretty much the exact same you know
it's funny did you ever think that you'd
be here go and talk about like
conversations with god and [ __ ] like
what happened to you i i mean like it's
something that began
for me like before sobriety and [ __ ] you
know like i did drugs to the point where
uh
where
the compartments
between
different things yeah eroded yeah and
and i really really uh
latch on it resonates with me what you
said about the the frequencies high
frequency is love and then down here it
gets darker and you know and um
from for me drugs became
super spiritual
like um
where
i had uh
hallucinations i was hearing voices i
was like seeing like odd like like i was
seeing people walk around who were never
physically there i was hearing voices i
was it was just all of this other
worldly [ __ ] and and i was so
[ __ ]
like blown away by it i loved it so much
i just kept piling more drugs into my
body to keep it happening yeah this was
my spiritual connection and um
the thing
about that it as it was as fascinating
as it was as much as i loved it like it
i recognized that that was a dangerous
approach to spirituality because the the
dr i believe the drugs i was doing
eroded
the the barriers between other uh yeah
it's like it's opening up the dial and
you're getting flooded with so much [ __ ]
but it's but by doing it that way you're
letting in like just all [ __ ] who
knows what's coming in demon ass [ __ ]
yeah you're tuned into a radio station
and you said let's just listen to all
the stations at once
you know what drug
did it the most free what drug does all
the barriers the most or was it like it
was three days of cocaine and and
huffing like
nitrous oxide that's gnarly what if he
said estrogen he's i used to do so much
estrogen it was insane dude that's heavy
yeah i mean people do it would always be
three days of cocaine and i would
basically do to do cocaine for three
days and i'd be doing nitrous inhaling
nitrous oxide the whole time and and and
the the more sleep deprived
yeah yeah they should have studied you
in the government because i think
they're like they got all into lsd and
all that [ __ ] and sexy i used to be the
stevo kid like we got to see what the
[ __ ] it's all he knows everything about
drugs let's [ __ ] figure it out but
were you like doing drugs like all right
day two i got one more day and then i
can start seeing some [ __ ] or it just
happened and i think day three his body
shutting down and he's probably time to
stop i don't know if it was a plan yeah
like it
generally day three was was where i was
uh it's like navy seal hell week except
they're not on coke but there's
sleep deprivation and stuff i i was on
my final stretch at that point but you
know like
compared to now
and i've got like when you were talking
about how we're uh
we're not reactive but we're we're
inducers we're inducers we're we're
creating our we're literally this is
quantum physics like we don't know this
but the scientists know this well i i
i'm so so struck by that because um
for uh
for
924
consecutive days i've maintained an
average of over 40 minutes of meditation
every single day that's [ __ ] great
dude everyone is terrified to stop well
let me tell you something that's really
dope so
um my friend mark from blink
uh got cancer and he's cool now like he
got it all like it's all taken care of
but when it happened
i was like i know that energy healing
works and so i called up my partner from
cia and he goes dude he's all it's very
real he's all whenever we have people
within the agency that gets sick we send
them to this one guy
and what they do
is it's a really cool story there's a
phd that sells do those energy healing
you know and he's like
well i want to test you in the lab and
so they set up all these experiments all
these mice gave all the mice cancer and
the day before or something that the
energy healer was like i can't do it.
and so they're just going to shut the
thing down but then one of the the clin
the the technicians told the phd
guy she's like well why don't you just
do it you knew what he was doing he goes
i can't do it he's like special no he
just puts his hands near something and
focuses in tension and whatever just do
it you already spent the money you
already got the [ __ ] mice that are
sick well all of these mice
were 100 not 90 not 70
100
going to die on day 27 because they gave
him that type of cancer they do it all
time so he goes up there and he goes
okay spends a few hours each day hands
on the cage just intending all you do is
focus on destroying the tumors helping
healthy healthy healthy mice nothing's
happening it's like week two and there's
a [ __ ] nothing happening so he's
going to cancel she's not just keep
going just do the full [ __ ] 27 days
well like on day 20 21 the tumors start
exploding starts healing all the mice
they take the blood out of the mice go
to a different cage put it in there but
[ __ ] heals those mice no another mice
can ever get that cancer again
they then do energy healing on a cotton
swab and they smell the cotton swab
across the country put that cotton swab
in with some ice it heals those [ __ ]
mice and what it's led to was a profound
discovery that consciousness again
is what dictates physical everything and
if you meditate
or you pray
or you get on your knees and [ __ ]
focus on it doesn't matter when you shut
your mind down and open up bandwidth to
god source it doesn't physics doesn't
care if you think it's all odd jesus
consciousness just just
shut your mind down you can do anything
because you're a transducer of your
environment so you can heal [ __ ] you can
heal cancer you can walk on water like
jesus you can lay on a bed of nails you
can walk across fire you can levitate my
my partner
physicist was dispatched by the dod to
the middle east to check out these dudes
that were meditating and levitating like
we see in cartoons you know like ooh you
know the snake comes out and
that was happening
and they couldn't understand why because
it was consciousness
like so my point is is like we're so
powerful we don't even know it and i'm
not saying i know how to do all this
[ __ ] but i'm telling you it's like real
for sure
i'm terrified of ever missing a
meditation like i'd keep track of it on
an app
this is what you need i'm not saying i
know how to do this but you you're you
meditate like way more than i do and i
wish i did it like you but what the real
goal
is to meditate
while you're walking around
and that's like monk [ __ ] that's a jedi
my my deal is like mantra meditation so
like i'm just sitting still and uh yeah
could you imagine if like right now
you're [ __ ] locked in
yeah i mean
you'd be like luke skywalker i'm telling
you
it's like jedi [ __ ] i mean i i really
subscribed to it here's something that
i've um
i i've said said a lot like um
we were talking about it this morning
you know like the most people's problem
is that they don't have a a goal yeah
you can't accomplish
you can't accomplish something without
first identifying
what you want to accomplish because when
you have a purpose or a goal you are
creating that remember like if you don't
have one what are you creating like if
you're working towards something you're
envisioning it you're thinking about it
you're planning it you're making steps
to get there that is manifesting that
reality that's how it starts and if you
don't have that then it's kind of vacant
you know for sure and uh and and once
you've identified a goal
then
intelligence is is helpful for sort of
conceiving ways to to
you know accomplish it um
certainly uh talent is helpful you know
for like
but
nothing
comes [ __ ] close to enthusiasm
interesting enthusiasm is the engine
which drives the human experience like
it doesn't matter
it doesn't [ __ ] matter if i'm
talented or intelligent if i [ __ ]
have passion then i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm
gonna make it happen and then as i i i
related this you know this uh
many times and then just out of nowhere
somebody offered up on their own without
me even
they said uh
the the latin
root for the word enthusiasm
is en theos which means with god wow
it's dope so love that it's cool yeah so
when you're when you're when you're
[ __ ] on fire for something you're
with god you're with god you're doing
god's work doing the lord's work and and
i love that too man so when you're horny
and you're really passionately horny
i'm with god yeah i mean uh i you know i
whenever um
whenever people historically and you
know would ask me advice on something
say
you know
like
how do i
do this well you know my first advice is
whatever it is you want to
do or get good at
start doing it don't wait for for
someone to pick you don't wait for this
to line up
you know start doing it with one caveat
make sure that that you're not uh that
you're starting that you're learning the
right way because because we can like
get all on one and then start like
learning bad habits you don't want to
learn bad habits that you're gonna have
to unlearn so maybe find a mentor
somebody who's uh done it before for
somebody who can make sure you're on the
right track like notice right yeah fine
find a way to make sure that you're
learning the correct way but waste no
time start doing it and then i would say
it doesn't matter what you want
to accomplish it simply matters how
[ __ ] bad you want it oh i so agree
that that enthusiasm and uh
and i think that that for me this is
where my meditation comes in
is that uh
is is that
it
if i i feel
that it it plugs me in
i plug into this [ __ ] source whatever
where like i bring
i've got the inten the intention you
know i've got the intention i've got the
[ __ ] enthusiasm and i just plug into
the the
the source
which i really
i
[ __ ] believe that the universe
conspires in my favor because i meditate
no it does dude trust me you're not the
first person that that that works for
like i know people that are so hardcore
on that because it literally dictates
everything else is calm clear present
and things just start happening for you
because you connect and you let all the
[ __ ] go
and you just get like this the juice of
fuel that you need i mean you're a
consciousness
you know you're a being that's living
through consciousness so
why would you not stop to reful fuel
that tank you know i i totally subscribe
to it and i think it's really awesome
that you do it you know what thanks man
yeah when we were when i first met mario
our buddy mario he said he grew up with
you and and you know new mexico and he
said you just always go to people like
hi my name is steve i'm gonna be on tv
one day
i love that
and and the i think the difference
between you and somebody else is like
uh
correct me if i'm wrong but was there
any doubt that one day you'd be on tv
or did you know i i was uh
pretty
cause that's enthusiasm yeah
tireless enthusiasm um i i
believed that one of two things was
gonna happen i was gonna either make my
mark and become famous in life or uh all
of the
the video that i was
you know recording and effectively
stepping into a bottle would be
discovered after i died
yeah one of the two but you will make it
cool yeah
that was everything that i was about i
was like oh dude this footage lives
forever like this footage so let me make
sure this footage is [ __ ] bad i gotta
do i gotta tell you when you did the
[ __ ]
wild boy with wild voices yeah that
thing with the hot dogs and the lions
was the gnarliest thing i think i've
ever seen in my life
that like because you just remember you
falling from the hammock into the lions
right the [ __ ] were you guys thinking so
heavy yeah it was heavy the uh
the first trip we took to
to film the
pilot for for wild boys we went out to
south africa because that's where they
had the great white sharks we wanted to
jump off the boat and next to the great
white shark
that was like the main reason why we did
the pilot in south africa we also
we also brought a zebra suit two-man
zebra suit
for us to go on safari we wanted to get
a shot with the lion
they told us
like that's not how it [ __ ] works you
don't [ __ ] you know like like you
don't [ __ ] around with lines like that
nobody we brought the suit out there
we brought the zebra scene out there to
do that and they're they're like no no
no so like we we would get in the zebra
suit on safari like when there was like
different scenes going on but never with
an actual line around because no one
would let us do that so we had all this
footage and then we're like well [ __ ]
what are we gonna do and they had this
company called hollywood animals in
california and so we got the final shot
the final bit was it was shot in uh
in california with one of these [ __ ]
so funny yeah and so everything that
we're with lions like like up in the
tree with the lions you know like that's
hollywood animals it's still scary
dude i don't give a [ __ ] that's a lion
dude was it not a lion also that's still
alive
gnarly
my closest call with death was was uh a
lion climbing up a tree and getting all
on me and like moments before
i uh
had made some snarky comment about
siegfried and roy it was like oh
i got a major life lesson but dude like
among the most fascinating [ __ ]
conversations we've ever had oh good dan
i appreciate that yeah yeah sure i i
appreciate both you guys
i gotta jump back in the studio um yeah
we appreciate you yeah thank you so much
and um yeah
like anything i'm gonna steal this from
mike tyson every time
there's millions of people
what do you want to say to them
uh what i want to say um what do i want
to say to all these people i want to say
that
a lot of people don't understand me or
my thinking or what i'm doing a lot of
people hear the ufo thing i don't really
get it
my company to the stars has really
gotten itself in a really cool position
to help you understand all these things
uh that are a lot to digest for people
and it still comes from this kind of
rebellious punk rock skateboarder youth
that i've always been which was like
kind of do my own thing you know and i
chase things that i think can make the
world cooler or better or funnier or
happier and um i really believe that i'm
kind of in the in the epicenter of a lot
of really cool things but you know
that are going to really influence
the world but the the movies and all the
things i'm making are really a direct
result
of
the people i work with the things that
i've figured out the things that we're
doing with the government and like
really trying to get people to
understand that you're powerful you're
[ __ ] awesome and you can make life
what you want it you just gotta
understand how it works and that's kind
of the realm that i think humans are in
right now we're gonna start to learn
because it's been secret for so long
what we're capable of and how this all
works and it's going to profoundly
change the human experience in a way
that you're already discovering you i
don't know man you're just not doing it
yeah questionable that's questionable
all right thank you guys so much yeah
man
brother that was great
all right kids it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude